by travelpod member
all right welcome everyone to another
episode of the Friday review and as
always I'm Dan Galpin and this is ian
new Lewis joining us today as always as
big Pete in spirit spirit today we're
drinking what purports to be the last of
the great red rice sales of Japan it's
called oh it's a talk to Nellore nasty
and it is it is a really good no my eye
I approve so yeah excellent quite good
well selected sir today we are we're
going to be reviewing five games eye
candy carnage Elvis colony defender gobe
Android and word hero and this is this
isn't this is a fun selection of games
so I guess we're starting with candy
carnage oh yeah because where better to
start than candy carnage so candy
cartridge is a really simple game and
and it like many of Handy games games
has well a little bit of an offbeat
could be we get this on here the the
warning ya the warning is definitely
worthwhile this the following game
contains insanely aggressive butchers
every scene was performed by
well-trained scut mended butcher costume
nope attracted work hardened with
Harvard the creation of the game
developers insists that no one attempts
to recreate or reenact any action or
event at the game further information
please ask to your local supermarket
employee Packer what I really love about
that is that's only one of several
disclaimers yes they say randomized it
so candy carnage was done by a small
group with in handy games I think they
said they were their youngest grew
youngest group III think the matter how
young they must yeah I think well you
know given given the style of game they
certainly could be at the four-year-old
level of game you know as far as the
game design is concerned but i think it
was it's a great young team that's
exciting to see that you know they
produce something fun just kind of
initial technote this game does sadly
play music on the washing and and so
that's probably probably being the
youngest group they didn't get the note
from the rest of the rest of the groups
of handy games you know what they
probably prank them it probably did
Holly that's like that oh yeah a nature
that music starts as soon as the lock
screen comes up because otherwise you
get dinged also the you know for for the
art style that we're seeing here which
is vector art honestly it's a little bit
blurry at this 720p resolution a little
difficult to tell probably on on the
YouTube channel but it's just it's not a
hundred percent crisp and I don't know
why it's just like it's being stretched
just a little bit yeah you really say
that actually when you zoom you see it
zoom in during intros the level right
but but the game is is well thought out
and can be in carnage now this actually
I have one thing to say about this when
I first played this game um I saw kandi
I thought carnage I thought oh okay so i
can either play as the good guys or the
bad guys right there little cute
princesses or the butcher's prove that
that's not the case candy is what more
of a level based and carnage is kind of
like the last is till you die right at
the clay so carnage you're dead they're
guaranteed to die and that's not the
only reason why it's called carnage but
it's the same game but honestly I I
sucked at this game right at first but
the game actually has a lot of
interstitials that tell you how to play
it mmm they just they don't appear until
you've already dropped into the game and
humiliated yourself not sure how I feel
about that but I particularly like this
the following game contains the cruel
trampling of candy by fleeing princesses
all scenes were performed by
professional stunt candy no piece of
candy was eaten or otherwise harm during
the creation began I don't believe that
by the way I know I would my blade I'm
sure about why I had candy fetches my
dating 10 is the following game contains
scenes of princesses being fed into a
woodchopper no wood chopper was hard
that's alright so this is I it's a very
simple game mechanic anyway I knew I did
perversely fun yeah anything you just
think the Germans had a sense of humor
this is this is this is proposed that
they do yep this let me put it this way
this game makes me forgive have handy
games for happy Vikings
whole thing a lot Wow and they loved
that game so you know I can't figure it
out but simply some users apparently oh
you just lost one I did yeah you know I
really want to see actually no game I
really want to see some sort of combo
mechanism where I sway this is a combo
that's that's it if you if you get more
than you get to get in a row though it
doesn't matter if you tap them like I
want to see like a sweet combo like
where I'm sleeping with one finger well
I family is only when you sweet no no it
just didn't even sits the okay now this
um I've got two complaints about this
what you see on the screen now I pretty
common not really a problem but first
it's it's a system dialogue and when
you've gone to so much effort to make
your entire game you I so pretty and
custom and beautiful and then you drop
an Android system UI dialog in there
just just the best possible dial I will
give them some credit they actually have
targeted this at SDK version at least 11
because you're seeing actually a hollow
base system dialogue yes a nice yeah I'm
not play no no no and also I will point
out this does not have the menus of the
menu of shame on it and it also does
something very very cool which you can't
see from the broadcast but it actually
turns it actually during gameplay will
dim the menu bar just for extra for
extra levels of immerse siddity so it
puts it in lights-out mode yeah it puts
into life out yeah all games really
should do yeah yeah there's only
abilities little reason not to
especially the Tino intended to be kind
of an immersive shame by the other thing
is you know plz rate of five stars like
users can't figure out that if they like
the game they should be rating
estimating it five stars we would prefer
something that yeah that respects users
a little more it's like why don't you
rate this game yep tell me what you
think yeah tell us is P if you love the
game rate us you know something like
that if you don't love the game don't
rate us please that would you can be
acceptable but writing us by telling
people to rate you five stars is sort of
like you know it's not cool but in any
case it's a fun game it's got a really
simple mechanic but it's sort of
addictive I love the way they've used
vibration in this because if i hit a
butcher all of a sudden I not only do I
get closer now to the the rotating
spikes of death but also I get this
really long buzz sounded just like it
feels visceral I love the I love the
fact that the transformer prime actually
supports a vibrator to that's kind of
cool not all tablets do so right do we
call it the vibrator is that the
official name a vibration out or you
know whatever like that yeah okay just
try great functionality anyway but yeah
you can see that it's it does almost you
know aside from having music on the lock
strange is almost everything right and
it's a really fun little game ya don't
know if we could actually sneak this one
past merchandising for a feature slot
but what the hey will I will nominate it
anyways yeah that's right I thought we
could just see that see that the sadness
in their eyes oh yeah the the animations
in the art worker just hilarious so yeah
well done you guys yep alright so the
next one and is another sort of cutesy
princess game although i'm just going to
say this um when I started this game if
you go to know let's see not sure if you
can see it well the the icon here mm-hmm
for this game is so frightening hmm yeah
I am let me let me actually bring this
up in the oh well let me not do that
then okay fine google play we have a lot
of accounting this that that's logged
into this gets periodically shut down by
people who don't know who we are in any
case I the icon has this like really
really scary looking girl on it and then
the feature graphic for the game has
this like super cute see anime you know
Red Riding Hood and I'm like really so
this is what you wanted to go with for
the icon because it's kind of scary well
the other thing and I'll say this I like
taking this bed all icons is that
that you know this icon you know it once
again it's using rounded rectangles for
no apparent reason like there's you know
this is yep it's like why like it could
be just as nice using you know you have
you have this cool background you have
this cool you know why it why not use
some translucent sees and transparency
be really cool we had a whole crop of
those this week you know we understand
that in some parts of the world rounded
rectangles are considered very important
and Android has never felt that way in
fact it looks less like an Android app
if you have a rounded rectangle on your
icon and for some of these you know like
why does go android have a rounded
record rectangle why does Elvis have a
rounded rectangle those things could
just easily not have the rectangle look
much better now candy carnage has a
rounded rectangle and it really doesn't
need it like that it'd be cool just to
have her without the background but i
will say at least the icon is the
correct size well offices and N word
hero are both and banned red banner it's
the correct size also the other ones are
actually taking up more space in the
standard Android icons do and they
really stick out as being something that
feels non-native it's a shameful war
hero which is a totally native game so
so realize a you know this is this is
sort of our our fault we we gave
everyone too much freedom and you know
this is why we can't have nice things
now we believe in freedom here and you
know yeah and it's want to make that
clear but on the other what happens
isn't it we believe in a consistent
visual style as well and and you know
and you which we try within our own
applications to kind of have that and we
really hope that you guys help us out by
making sure your applications have that
have a nice consistent visual style so I
would love to see current candy carnage
lose the rounded rectangle and just have
the girl I'm not absolutely if the radar
guidelines you know the reason that
there's this much space available for
the icon is because we we intend for it
to be an odd shape and size if it is
just a square then it should fit in the
woods of 96 96 or something smaller size
ya hota it should be with it I think it
should we want a border of like what is
it 15 or 20 personas they something like
that but we at least I look at the
guidelines I haven't yeah I don't have
memorized but but there you know
the point is that we want we want icons
to have the freedom to pop out of the
border but when you make your border the
absolute max sighs you lose that and you
make your game look completely
unbalanced compared to the rest of you
and kudos the candy card is for at least
partially popping out of the border by
the way that's such the like little
groundhog one mile in one or two yeah no
it's not it's closer it's closer but
again too nice for your 1 pixel out
you've read actly exactly so uh let's
let's go back to L Delta yeah alright so
first of all it doesn't actually restart
the game don't confuse letterboxing here
on this on the wall white screen at the
beginning and then letterboxing here
very clearly visible on the game itself
which says to me in so many ways this
game was not actually built for this
platform mom if you see the game the
graphics nothing in this game feels at
all like it was built for a mobile
device how badly is it letterboxed on on
yours that isn't plugged in though yeah
see it's love it's a little less yeah so
um it's honestly this is on the edge
like we'd prefer obviously that every
app always fill the entire screen and
without automatic stretched out very
right work but you know it if you've got
a piece of art that you know you can't
do that with and its author dat about
sixteen by nine yeah that's fine in this
particular case the hdmi out on the AC
transformer prime actually adds some
pixels at the bottom for some reason so
it changes the aspect ratio to display a
little bit now what one thing tonight
it's actually seven so it's the aspect
ratio of the transformer prime through
this is actually 720p so this when
you're seeing here with a letter boxing
on the side is actually what it would
look like on any of the droids which all
have the same aspect ratio cool yeah so
this is this is so it actually without
the hdmi or its actual little narrower
it's a little closer to a lot of the
standard Android devices so it's
somewhere in between so my feeling is I
still think this is too much but you
really get to see it through the hdmi
out which is nice another other note on
this title screen is that it's kind of
sad because the logo is actually really
really poorly anti-aliased against the
background it's just
sort of it feels like they didn't like
they chop the logo from something else
and then and then there's all of this
kind of leftover anti-aliasing junk on
it and then they threw it onto this
background which makes me really sad
like honestly it's like when you know
it's like they've got to disabuse
artwork and then to kind of throw kind
of a I don't know a poorly done yeah I
got you know I don't know i'm not sure
if I agree with you I think that the
intent may have been to try and put some
some highlights around the edges and
give it a little bit of a pop but but if
that were the intent that's sort of Sun
sabotage by the fact that it's really
really really pixelated yeah I don't
think that's the intent I just that but
but maybe you know like it certainly
could be but this game is is an example
of trying to do things right kind of but
not really and you know and we think we
can continue on with the game itself I
particular eyes like the news banner
that shows up here with with with it
with you dashes on it it doesn't know it
doesn't show up on yours but um but when
you go to get you get that you get this
menu here at the front and the expected
behavior is you hit the back key and you
probably should just quit but it does
pop up this dialog that says quick game
would you know anywhere you were
absolutely free to use my pebble yeah
she's yours or viewers tonight guys we
can switch over to the tab oh let's just
kind of walk through kind of this
initial so so we look at you get you
have to put you hit the play button and
we get to 10 * joining us which is kind
of unfortunately underneath the ad um it
just seems like if you're going to put
up an ad for your thing that this is a
really good time to show some detail and
actually put down the ad that's actually
you're using to help pay for the game on
the way at the back you hear I get in a
quick game rather than dismissing that
which is kind of weird um and also I
look at the X in the oh and I think of
the X is the PlayStation X and I'm night
I actually look like I have no idea
which one quits that was my first thing
it absolutely is the 0 that quits and
the X actually take way too seriously
dialogue yo quits which I didn't get
right liquor taxes like Diego yeah but I
look at that I'm like that must be now
maybe that's maybe that's a Korean thing
that bed that that's more common but I
usually think of like the check marks
and an ex or something as being that the
most common you know the most common
symbols for that but even you know even
better yes and no is kind of
good option too BTW beno d flat but the
other thing is that you know in
realistic game up here you might as well
just have it leave the game like yeah I
mean well we we certainly have told
people for many months now that the back
button should never quit the action it
shouldn't just pull you out of the game
with no way to get right back in but the
intent of that rule is to make it so you
don't accidentally hit the back button
and lose progress the intent is not to
say you've got to show a confirmation
dialog with whenever anyone tries to get
out of your game at any stage and
honestly it shouldn't quit the game
because right now or wait if I'm
entitled agreeing yeah this is the achs
exile shooting another thing here we
will switch back to the tablet so this
is just you know lack of attention to
detail here so this is great get a
little menu here you hit the back key
and that dismisses it you click here you
at the back eat it just misses that you
click on the third one and it brings up
this dialog which we saw before and you
hit the back key and it goes to quit
game so you know this what is it and go
stick wit you yeah and if you hit the
back again it dismisses that again
that's reasonable it looks like a
dialogue but it just this is a sort of
attention to detail like that you know
the kind of expectation is we want the
navigation if field consistent and this
just already doesn't so Ari says to me
someone didn't pay attention they could
click later here and actually go into
the game um and so one thing you're
seeing in this game is it it's really
really low low low resolution graphics
and and that was fine like five years
ago but you know what is it you probably
last year and it's okay for you know
there is a market or you know sort of
this like super nintendo style totally
mix right um but I see the other thing
about it and even if even if you you
know get over the fact that graphics are
a really low res but I'd love to see is
the gameplay feels smooth like it
actually feels like it's running in an
emulator like you know it's like you
know it's like I mean if you're gonna
have low res graphic to the style that's
great but it doesn't actually have to
play like it's running on a machine you
know from ten years ago and like you can
watch it's getting about you know ten
frames a second at most
maybe five frames a second is doing a
lot of these transactions and it's just
kind of sad like you know this is this
is you know these these these phones are
super powerful things the other thing is
we're now within this menu and you know
hitting the back he doesn't do anything
at all right Dan's trying to just punch
the back key and it's just it just yeah
so so that's that that's another thing
is that like you should never beat a
point even if you're in the middle of
some sort of scene Justine like this
hitting the back you should do something
and I think we also you know just want
to take a look at I don't know if we
could switch to this and oh yes you show
off in my Iain yeah that's a camera to
raita so yeah we have I we have these
menu buttons down here yeah this is a
menu button that does nothing now Dan
had a really good point I it's perfectly
legitimate to actually just dim this
entire system bar that's kind of a cool
way to handle things on a tablet but if
you're not going to dim it at least make
it so this button goes away and the way
that you do that of course is by
specifying napi level of 14 or greater
so you know watch that and yeah in the
back page we say it doesn't do anything
in this mode so you can you can you can
tap it all you want it's kind of that we
can go back to the tablet itself and
kind of continue looking at it so then
again this is this is very obviously um
yep pixelated by intense so that's sort
of the style a lots of these texts
things I mean this is definitely like a
you know it is a in this case k RPG yeah
it's a you know PSP style game so we
know what we're getting into you there
but again you know even with this type
of game we're expecting a high frame
rate and we're expecting it to be
controllable so that was actually one of
the problems I had yeah was that the
controls are a little ring here it now
remember with this ring I you know
you're certainly um you should be
falling into sort of Au Au I paradigm
that's become very popular rehab sort of
virtual joystick on the left hand side
here but it actually this is more of a
d-pad there
there is a right there is a left and
there is down and you can't you know you
can't promise I'll taneously it's sort
of difficult to go from one to the other
yeah it's one thing if this the so this
is a tablet problem here so it's
designed this thing is designed for
something that has a much much lower DPI
then we have here so the control just
being scaled up the way the rest of the
game is and so the d-pad is really hard
to control you're absolutely right i
think that's a big part of it but you
know let me make an argument to that
this again is sort of design though that
worked okay you know last year but in
yeah in the last year 18 months or so I
we've really moved in the direction of
much more usable controls and what you
see in most games now is a UH something
that takes into account where you placed
your thumb to begin with and looks at it
relatively instead of making you place
your thumb at a salsa phic point on the
strategy even further you and eat with
for this particular game I mean I see
these arrows here and I my first thought
was oh cool arrows and you know there's
no reason when I tap here that my
character shouldn't go oh that means
what I wanted to do was move to that to
that to that position and jump you know
I'm tapping above am I'm tapping to the
left i'm talking to the right of my
character i expect something to happen
because that's the modern control system
of this kind of game i can just
literally hold the button here in you
choose really what you're saying is it
would be very very interesting for for
this game to be more of a touch game and
less of a joystick game yeah I mean it
really feels like an emulator like if I
had no yeah I I think you can make an
argument either way I mean because
really what you're saying is you want it
to be a different game well i do think i
spent a ton of time just fighting the
controls yeah especially that one yeah
yeah I can't count how many times I fell
off that little tiny ledge yeah I and
yeah they're not very responsive like
the controls you're supposed to fight
the bad guy in a game yeah the
combination of you know really really
low framerate emulated gameplay you know
the emulator light gameplay you know the
only reason that a marketing team is
going to look at this and be like oh my
god you want to pull this to put this in
front of users is if we're doing now
going to old school week and these are
and these are games that were expecting
to suck and so we're going to put up a
whole bunch of games was really bad that
that's harsh that's harsh I always do
you like this is like a Zach a RPG this
is you can do so much better than this
and honestly you know it's like it just
feels like there was zero effort place
to thinking about the mobile experience
how do we take this game design which
works somewhere else and smash it onto
mobile without making huge changes ball
game boy or something like that I'm with
you on that honestly though um maybe and
now yoga who have better eyes all night
when you I don't think that it has that
low frame rate I just think that the the
idle animation is only two frames long
but look I mean you can see here like
where we're getting we're getting into
something on the order of maybe maybe 15
at most frames a second you know and
that's scrolling it's certainly not
hitting through 30 but you know and and
the thing is that it's but it's not just
at it it's like to me it's like there's
so many people who are actually
targeting mobile mm-hmm you know it's
like so why would the marketing team
ever want to say let's take this app
which was clearly smashed into the
platform with very little thought as do
how it was going to target mobile when
there's so many developers out there for
developing awesome experiences around
mobile and even developers who are
taking old art styles like this and
doing really cool stuff in designing a
game around mobile so unless the game is
just so rich and full of content that
that it did it overcomes all of us and
with the control of the game if it's
game controlled well right.we despite
everything else I would tilt yeah it
really feels so non-native with the
letter box and everything but at least I
could forgive it but with the
combination of the controls that are
kind of difficult to play with it really
it's harped me to actually look at this
and say this is experience that most
Android users are going to want to play
now you know knowing this developer
would you yeah I think it's safe to say
that the game is rich in full cut a
dilute I known very well for that and I
think that I think this game will
absolutely find a huge audience
absolutely yeah but we this is a sort of
thing we would call a cult classic a
cult favorite yeah for the reason that
you know when you join a cult they give
you a copy of it
okay no because it is something that
really really appeals to a very small
segment of the market um and it's
awesome those are good seeing that yeah
it's just it's difficult for us to
justify trying to get this featured um
when we know that there's going to be
some people that see that in the store
and think well I you know I don't want
it by that or man i would actually would
love to see like a set of titles that
these are these are really
representative of this genre but I
actually think there's much better
representatives of this genre and we're
seeing now what people are doing play
this through a little bit more I are
intrigued by the story yeah story is you
you go back and forth they've got some
humor when he when you finally get to
this little guy he's like he's making a
joke about her old comp to us gameplay
get some inside joke sorry I I think
it's fun yeah I just I just think that
you know there are people right never
taking these k RPGs and and they're
actually writing them as if as if as if
they were written for a mobile platform
and you know and we're seeing higher
resolution artwork we're seeing things
that are designed for both plastic
ratios this is a tile-based game there's
no reason why this game has to be
limited in aspect ratio what's with a
little bit of thought in design this
game would work fine on this aspect
ratio it's literally just taking tiles
and I want to see another half hilum you
on either side and I want that to be
designed into into the architecture of
the game so that's not showing me
something I'm not supposed to see you
know but but it's not hard to do if you
think about it from the beginning now if
this game was just ported and my
assumption is it is because i really
hope no one took to mobile and worked so
hard to design a game that look nothing
like a mobile game but but if this game
was imported then obviously I would
expect them to have thought of those
things right and lastly you know I just
wanted I want to say this again because
so many games have this problem if we
could switched it the camera there I
just want you to see you know and
remember i don't have the largest hands
in the world or largest thumbs but my
thumb is just barely large enough to
take to hit this these buttons the
directional controls and when I come
over here I mean this these it hurts
to hit the jump button it should work to
hit the jump button that makes no sense
yeah I'm going to be hitting that all
the time a lot more than this big I mean
I mean what I would love to see and
honestly is it is a couple of eggs one
is if you're going to build something
which is kind of sort of an emulator
overlay with emulated controls spend a
lot of time thinking about that HUD this
is what the user is seeing the entire
game like I want it so the one thing is
it to me it doesn't see it shouldn't
feel like it needs to be low res because
this is an overlay basically on top of a
game if it was even ported from
something else this wasn't part of the
original game you know because the
original game presumably was meant for
something that actually had but none so
we and we've got the simplest tub we've
got two buttons that are always the same
and we've got three with a three
position controller so it's it is very
very straightforward you know what the
game is trying to do and what I what I
want to see is well you know let's let's
say I want to touch the controller here
I want to be auto scale there's no
reason why I shouldn't be lit up the
screen at this top point here which is
not nothing to be pointing out i
shouldn'ta controller just shouldn't
move if we're really going to do the
style of control or even better you know
think about you know actually are
projected into the game these two
buttons here I should go I should be
able to get into a mode where I can
click drag them and move them rescale
them you know if you're really going to
go with the HUD thing or even better try
to do something that you know look I'm
on an extra large screen device let's
let's let's take advantage you know I'm
going to go with that last suggestion as
my favorite because I hate it when a
game gives me lots of programmability
but doesn't give me reasonable default
yeah that one thing that we've learned
in software design over the past 10 to
20 years is you can give people all
sorts of customizability but what they
really love is just figuring the damn
thing out to begin with yeah and making
it comfortable and then maybe giving you
soap so the key is as you're saying yeah
look at the screen size and density you
know android has has made an entire
cottage industry of figuring this stuff
out and giving you the data that you
need to make your screen the right size
the right density you know inside your
controls irregardless of what the model
I mean if if you literally just took
this control scheme split it in half and
scaled it based upon density it would
actually play pretty well in this tablet
especially if we got rid of the black
brown the slide
you know just because that's because
those are also making you reach farther
it really is it's the reach that makes
that make these buttons challenging but
and it on a phone this game plays fine
it looks a lot better because because
smaller artwork just looks better on
phones you know and you know you don't
notice that excite pic slave yeah so
very true now first I need to I need to
interrupt our broadcast for just a
second to admit that I used the word
irregardless in a sentence which means
of course we need to take a shot sorry
yeah mmm alright that's that's yeah
sorry about that a flogging will
commence after the show one thing that
you should be aware of is that um in the
game space you are very unlikely to get
featured unless your game plays very
well on tablets and the reason for that
is just you know we've had many
conversations with the featuring team I
and in general as soon as we have a
critical mass of games that do a
particular thing right there's no reason
to consider games that don't do that
particularly attic exactly a blitz are
extremely important to Android and the
google play store well and more
importantly you know we see that people
with Android tablets buy more games you
know and play more games you know per
user then phone so we know that the debt
there is there is a little impassioned
community and we're trying to serve that
community by making sure that when they
have an awesome game on their phone they
can also play it on the tablet and it's
honestly for most games it's really not
that much work like the amount of work
that was spent designing all of the
content in this game and developing this
game is huge and a tiny tiny bit of
polish that would have taken by
comparison to get it to play while on a
tablet is so small and that's why I
makes me so sad like I look at this game
like there is lost potential here in all
sorts of ways there's lost potential and
having a frame rate not sync up to this
to to what the device is capable of
doing there's lost potential and having
it letterbox when it really designed
doesn't really require that there's lost
potential and having the controls not
scale so that they feel right in your
hand and it's like I look at this and
like you know and then there's a little
tiny detail things and ultimately it
makes me feel like not a lot of effort
was put in
just bringing this to android and you
know and that's enough you know and I
hate making a value judgment but that's
what it feels like to me that feels like
feels like no we're just not respecting
our users and right and and I and I want
to see this game be awesome like every
other title I want to spend it harsh
words yeah man who knows his games
that's uh let's just take a quick break
for a second i want to address something
one last comment is game by though we
can move to the game screen charge
excuses okay okay so this is this is
that they're attempting to try to follow
our guidelines you get the bactine it
brings up this dialog and now we've said
in the past it's okay to bring up a
dialog with the back jaan it however the
reason why you bring up the dog is in
the middle game plan I don't want to
pause things we get into the staff
screen okay there's no way I can quit
out of here in fact right you have to go
on you want to find yourself like in the
city at least here yeah and then I'm
here and I'm like God I don't know what
quits either there's this home I guess
home must do something and then I get
here and I think all right I know the X
and O mean but I'm gonna assume the okay
takes you to take me to the main menu
and there you go I don't know how you
could make that simpler exactly so so my
feeling it I don't know this is another
weirdness in the game that I haven't
understood interesting okay no let's not
pile on anymore because honestly you
know that guys yeah I with so many great
game they tend to have and I honestly I
just want to see them I want to see them
continue to up their game you know cuz
they do awesome stuff I have I have you
know nephews nieces that are really into
I Asian RPGs actually love this stuff I
love Asian RPGs I have played like gold
and son forever I have played like tons
and on the Dreamcast I was a huge fan
that's the thing what I want to see is
games that are the level of the games
that i was playing on my ps1 you know
that that that's kind of that's kind of
far yes one it's kind of borderline you
know it's a in terms of I mean that's
kind of an eye holy is if all you know
of JRPGs is golden sun and you played it
on a dreamcast no no didn't have that
you know I feel mine
nintendo super duck that was has never
been excited lady who do not know yeah I
actually I actually played it on I on my
on my game boy advance that was the
Golden Sun was alright that was but but
any case but then that was you know that
was a game actually I'd love to see if
you have to the level of golden sun I
don't feel like this game is but yeah
that's yeah we're gonna make a pinkie
pact that the next week if we ever spent
half an hour talking about a game again
it'll be a game that we at least like I
think it's widen gets much easier to
talk about a game that has a lot of
problems like because that's true and
dissidents have some real promise it
does and I but I think this whole genre
like if all they did after this was take
a look at this and say hey let's really
make that HUD awesome wow that would be
amazing what then every other game that
they come out with it has a HUD could
improve and be something that we might
play that might be the case I need every
well might be the case and again I would
love to see us do more I think I think
the key arch RPG space is incredibly fun
and Italy Golden Sun was a JRPG let's
let's make that clear but but you know
it's a great space and and I want to see
us do what do it but in order to do that
we're going to people have to up their
game I want it you know in our I think
you're probably right and and actually
the same goes for for the next game that
we're going to look at but before we do
look at ax I just wanted a really quick
respondent to do something that came up
in the comments um and it's a bit of a
sensitive topic I want to you can't say
a lot but I think it's a topic that
comes up over and over again and I've no
idea what the fifth I'm I'm Carrie yeah
what so um so scan is really a jerk yeah
look yeah exactly it kind of here again
you look like a hippie yeah that's why
I'm wearing this hat because it's hard
to say the long hair right and is good i
hope you don't get in trouble what for
for cross marketing or not no no that's
true i guess i guess i guess yeah we had
to put big feet away cuz of the man yeah
okay we like I wouldn't antes us anyway
wait hey the point is um so so the
question was about intellectual property
theft you know just the idea that um
there there might be some people in the
world of that actually just go and
copy your game completely or even even
upload another game you know piracy or
trademarked after etc etc and and the
poster said why can't Google do
something about this I don't have the
time to issue a DMCA for for every
single etc etc we feel your pain um now
I am NOT a lawyer so please take what
I'm gonna say with a grain of salt my
understanding is that we yes not a
lawyer at all air my understanding is
what I've been told is we do need to ask
you to file a dmca because if we didn't
ask you to file a dmca there would be
certain liabilities on Google um that we
would get in trouble for essentially III
think I think I think I think ultimately
when you run a when you run a service as
a kind of a hoster hosting provider
there's something called the dmca safe
harbor and the goal is also not a lawyer
yeah also not a lawyer so I think that
said that that's the way that the store
tries to operate at the same time we we
do try and make a it is not my lawyer
hat no regular join a lawyer yeah
exactly so that's just to make it clear
basically looks like a clown giving this
advice so you can't possibly take it
seriously or legitimately with anything
other than the grain of salt on the
other hand five let's take down notices
because it helps everyone out now by the
way Rachel Meyer who's doing our
engineering for this session thinks that
it looks like a lawyer hat and I just
want to say to rato since you have lived
in both Britain and Australia I can
understand the mistake but dan is not a
barrister in intensive words now the but
we're trying to make is apparently they
think there are already a lot lawyers in
Australia and any of the UK as we think
here so there we are um so we we do want
to help you in and actually it is the
case we have we have banned people who
are in flagrant violation of trademarks
but there's a certain site there is dmca
there's trademark law there's a whole
set of intellectual property laws around
intellectual property on the internet
and we comply very carefully with those
laws because
believe me Google does not want to get
it wrong so when we ask you to do
something it's not because we're lazy or
we don't want to take the trouble it's
usually because it's the only way that
we can serve you and continue operating
services that we did it all in all us do
we know that all of your developers out
there put an enormous amount of effort
into bringing these properties to
Android we want to do our best to help
you you know both but in any way we can
in terms of getting a user base in terms
of helping you in ways of monetization
you know that's that's why we're here we
want to see the strongest and most
vibrant development developer community
can let's get you we have sorry little
time so let's write well so I think we
just got the message that mr. Lee who is
the author of gobe Android I can't join
from the country he's in which based on
his Google+ photo i assume is the united
states of awesome yeah sorry that we
can't get you in from that country but
so we may actually hold off on that one
I and we may actually have to hold off
on word hero as well but we definitely
want to talk about colony defender
because this is another game that is in
a genre that is awesome something that I
enjoy very much happening on the
scanning stuff up absolutely i'm so into
that stuff okay but um but I think that
it's sort of like the broadcast that we
do here which is awesome but
unprofessional yes yeah you know we are
not in any way professional broadcasting
guys no definitely not even when i put
on my professional broadcaster voice it
really just sounds like a cheap
imitation of a professional broadcaster
damn that voice is so rich and rewarding
if I thank you again are you let me both
can do the professional broadcaster
voice that will stop because we know
that will drive you well we want to see
the youtube videos the quiet moments
that we mention onto a handcrafted game
a colony defender which is kind of a fun
game um now the game that this reminds
me most of is droid hens game which they
called defender
it it does this makes me touch my screen
a lot more sorry go on way to think
about my screen all right so um no if
you put leading please don't get us for
copyright on that song it wasn't really
goodness rendition of it I think we're a
necrotic right here we do it developer
hang out of the Friday review no uh yeah
it's a you know you've got a gun in your
shooting things and there's kind of this
really cool backstory where you're being
instructed by this by your leader who it
turns out is completely evil mmm I
always loved that when you when you
finally realize you're working for evil
yeah we're sorry that doesn't happen to
be here I yeah yeah exactly it's why you
came here that's why I came here so um
so and there's some nice tension in this
game because after a while you will run
out of bullets essentially and have to
spend some time reloading I'm not sure
if it's actually possible to get through
a level without letting some of the
vehicles past you oh I've got now I've
gotten through the vball let me you just
have to really touch your skin a lot and
carefully yeah boy if you know exactly
where to touch it yeah actually they go
so so so there's some cool stuff there
the main problem that I have with this
game is that while it's really fun the
mechanics are fun and the the graphics
are maybe not as polished as the most
polished games pretty good you know
there's nothing obviously wrong with
them I very much like the way they
manage to work in absolute zero frames
of animation on the on the actual
graphics of the of the ships by have its
crew yes it's their kind of awesome
fight Wow there are some yet there have
been some corners cut on this game but
you know it is a good game but it makes
sense it's not like it's all like
there's no frames of animation because
because it's you know it because there's
someone it's a it's a care of you know
it kind of sitting by and and you know
actually just doing nothing there is our
presentation because
ships and they're made out of metal and
it don't reason they have to animate
when they fly so it i will say it the
fact they all move it precisely the same
speed and in the same exact direction
does somehow feel a little less you know
compelling than it otherwise be in this
pool area w can imagine you know things
that would make it feel more realistic i
think but i think it's a compelling came
the problem that i have with this game
is that it just hasn't been carefully
tuned yeah alafaya so if i compare it to
you know defender by droid head for
instance which is a very very similar
making its I it takes a lot longer to
get any upgrades in fact I can't upgrade
I can't even upgrade to get the missiles
that take out flying troops until I've
actually encountered something like five
or six levels with flying troops that
are really difficult to shoot down I
mean it I can't actually upgrade more
than like once every two levels you
might want to just front load a little
bit more of that make make it feel like
you're you're making more progress in
the beginning though um when I did
upgrade my cannon I mean this is like a
cannon I think I made it a cannon level
two at first I guess this is a new game
but I it didn't actually look any
different so and any one of the feelin's
was not actually all that noticeable so
it was difficult for me to get excited
about the progress that I was making you
know as far as I could tell the only the
only signal of progress at all in the
game was the fact that I had moved
another line over julia lee nondescript
4 by 4 square look if you look at the
screen right now you'll see there's a
set of squares on apparently we're
playing on Alpha Centauri and you can
see that you're progressing to move to
turning less of the squares from button
from black and white to color more the
stories like mine katoa so so I guess
what I'm really asking for just in
general is more of a reason to keep
playing now the other thing about this
game that I wanted to point out is with
a lot of as a lot of games I'm it does
have some trouble
when you try to background the game and
bring it back in the foreground so I'm
going to try to do that now we'll see
whether it reproduces the problems that
i was having go back into the game
through the icon if we can here we are
yes you've noticed that my Asus
Transformer Prime has a velocity
sensitive touch screen does an
impressive and the harder you tap on it
the more happens it is likely put in a
turbo this is actually there we are ok
so this is actually pretty good because
I actually did get back now the other
thing of course is when you're in the
middle of mission that was actually
where I accept fishin noting is it like
when you have something that someone
should do it needs to be kind of
highlighted in the UI is really really
clear it's nice as if this actually
blinked it be cool if accept mission
would actually also kind of height you
know blink remove or something to
highlight so now i'm going to push the
good old lock screen which is our
favorite thing let's go back into the
lock screen here and which one would be
music this is actually my oh it's yours
that sorry yeah sorry about that have
you shown the world your password now so
now we're here in the game and i really
don't know what what I'm supposed to be
doing now probably hitting continue this
is kind of cool um oh so nice cheap
there huh yeah I this is kind of awesome
so um obviously when you're when you're
developing something on a multi tasking
system like Android you really have to
take very seriously it's what happens
when you're actually multicast yeah and
we said it before would say it again the
key about Android isn't that it's a
multi processing system like you're
going to be doing a lot of things in the
background that's not that's not the
intent of the Android system ya hala ke
man exactly it's not about it's not
multitasking like a desktop system it's
multitasking as in you are holding this
device and you as a human being are a
multi tasker and you have stuff to do
and you're going to get notifications
and you're going to you know have your
bus come along and need to run to catch
it or get a call or you know anything
else the sort of here happens to people
to have friends especially they may
handle that and this game is casual
enough but it is the kind of thing I
could totally imagine pulling out while
I was waiting at a bus stop you know to
catch something or waiting for a train
and I might have a call coming in and
and if I lose progress because that call
comes in or because I accidentally hit
the lock button or you know whatever
that that's a bad thing so so obviously
you know this we have to look at things
you see it did actually recover from
this I don't you can't see it but if you
see actually it did finally kind of
figure out what was going on so that was
good but it definitely got into this
kind of funky state so it's definitely
to look at it's really important to look
at those android lifecycle charts as a
game developer because the expectation
is if you're using the framework the
framework actually does a lot of that
work for you but if you're actually as a
game developer you're probably not using
a lot of the framework so you're really
responsible to understand what happens
when your device goes into the
background when the lock screen is up
when the activity gets destroyed you're
really responsible for making sure that
it does all the right things your
threads get getting their paws or
destroyed or killed you know it went
when it when the system is going to the
life cycle and that will also make your
users happier so this game of course
like just about every other game we
looked at other than candy karnak's
today has hesitant many of shame it
doesn't he doesn't but it doesn't yeah
it wasn't black I would hold on this on
the camera camera too I because I just
want to make sure that we're that we're
showing these off so the the menu here
just that doesn't need to be there at
all yeah but even worse is this button
here now that's a that's a harder one to
see ah please see you know it's it's
four arrows pointing away from each
other when when I hit that button um no
okay they've managed to disable it
somehow which is really interesting mmm
yeah I wonder if it's because I got it
you got it oh yeah yeah what happened
though seemed well yeah i get i get
options to stretch or zoom to full
screen you don't want your users to do
this yeah neither one of those options
is good if you have a device or if i'm
sorry if you have a game that's capable
of running on a tablet device which this
game is obviously capable it really
doesn't have any resolution problems you
never want your users to do one of these
and also went into what ends up
happening is it sends a message to your
games telling it that your game is
resized and a surprising amount of games
don't actually handle the my screen as
been resized message very well no I'm
like this one is not doing a great job
of it
actually yeah I wouldn't you know I get
more time he had a wild bridge finish
now let's stretch to fill the screen and
zoom to fill screen by the way it took
me a long time to figure out what does
not yeah some stretch means that it's
going to tell your game that you are
actually on a larger screen well zoom
means it doesn't right Julie zoom
basically says oh yeah sure you're on
like a QB ad a screen sure is that what
you want all right and then it blows it
up really big I don't want I note that
basically what you're getting is the
that's kind of cool you're getting the g
one version of the game when you're
running the zoomed full screen the
assumption is that you actually have not
looked at the android platform since
android 10 pretty so if you want to take
a look at this at this tablet right now
so this is the entire screen of the
tablet it's a you know we haven't like
put it in one corner or not but that
that's basically what happened when when
I selected zoom to illustrate yeah
understandably this is probably not what
the developer intended and really kind
of cool though I have to get I make it
really hard to play and a cool oh aight
it doesn't doesn't know where we are on
the screen anymore because it's totally
lost right now it just assumes that if
we're zooming we must want Facebook that
makes sense actually call yeah that
whole like yeah I name the user
intentions absolutely i get some good is
Magic you I yeah so okay sarcasm mode
off we are out of time I but we do want
to congratulate the developer for making
what is actually a really night in I
gained yeah just not quite professional
quality and I think that with a little
bit more tuning and a little more
attention to gameplay detail it can
probably break that barrier any to say
well we'll probably will get to it next
week but I was I didn't want to say that
I have the word hero is super super fun
and I'm already really addicted to it
and I really really want to see a tablet
version of it like I think it really I
think it could be just totally awesome
with some tablet layouts and we have a
huge number of great thing and to say
about go band Roy yeah we basically
saved the best to lab and now that I
didn't get out so but i would actually
almost like to see with word he wrote
that the guys in the app review go over
it because i think it actually much more
akin to a lot of the applications we see
and I've let me kind of get our
get their UI feedback on it so if we can
if we could possibly do that next week
that would be awesome because I think
it's a really great opportunity rate
though it says in the Sun thumbs up he
does not know what he's getting into the
hall all right okay thanks everybody for
tuning in we do this every Friday and we
have a moderator page where you can
suggest your own app to be reviewed or
vote for apps that you like post
responses give some comments just join
the community of people who care about
android apps and games and we will see
you next week at one p.m. pacific time
friday for the Friday review thank you
very much cheers
you